I'm Darius Rucker and I love Purple Rain
the first time I saw Purple Rain I just
remember just being instantly changed
and this friend of mine Stacy Miller we
were already huge fans of Prince back to
controversy we already had this movie
out we thought that's awesome the movie
ended I just looked at her and said I
gotta see that again I gotta get back in
I gotta see this tomorrow
that movie blew me away you really liked
it I'm I growing up in an era where
music wasn't on TV all the time
you know music was something that was
all very audible to me it wasn't very
visual but when the time hit the stage
and just complete coolness of Morris a
day and they all did that one slide move
it they did man at that moment I was
like holy goodness I want to do that it
was one of those moments in my life that
helps shape away I went into that movie
that night never thinking about being in
a band always wanting to be a solo
artist I've never thought about ever
being in a band and I left that movie
and all I wanted to do was being a man
when he starts to sing Purple Rain
that's the moment in the movie for me
that's the moment
that's the I'm get jealous thing about
that's the yeah come to Jesus for lack
of a better word moment that's the
moment where he is realizing it was
never a one-man show over there and a
lot of that was he and how who you blow
fish crews built it really made me go am
I good enough you know but I tried to
prove I was I think that's what that
movie in the long run was about for me
thinking you can make it to you could
deal what you're doing is not crazy it
was Joyce to see something like that all
that big screen and it was important it
was it was it was a big moment in my
life hey I'm Darius Rucker
and I love movies
you